hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game I said I have prepared
for you this evening and I know what
you're all thinking dude even though
[ __ ] is not a chess player he's a
tennis player well you are right about
that but you might be surprised that he
really enjoys chess which shouldn't
really surprise you as I'm pretty sure
everyone enjoys chess he who says he
doesn't either doesn't know the rules or
he's lying for some reason I mean why
wouldn't someone enjoy chess now this
here game it was played online and well
even new which doesn't really need any
introduction but in case any of you
haven't heard of him I will just give a
couple of sentences in short now he's
been playing tennis for for the most
part of his life he turned pro in 1998
and he continued his professional tennis
career all the way until 2012 when he
played his last tournament and after
that he started managering and coaching
other players at the peak of his career
in 2006 he was ranked number 3 in the
world and I believe in 2013 after he
retired he started coaching Canadian
just a chess player Canadian tennis
player Milosh roundish and after that I
believe as of 2015 he is coaching his
old tennis rival Roger Federer so I was
very interested to see this game and the
reason I have this game is because
Lubitsch contacted me during the during
the 2018 candidates tournament he was
inquiring about some general questions
you know where I work and he watched the
candidates this and that and I was also
very impressed that he was interested in
chess so as of then we stayed in contact
and this game he sent it to me today so
this is the first game I've actually
seen him ever play and I really enjoyed
the ending so I asked him if it's okay
to show this game on my channel as he is
a very well known figure in the chess
world I thought it would be a nice way
to promote chess and I also asked him to
send me a couple of photos you know if
it'd be nice if they were
a high-resolution so he did send me a
couple of them let's let's just check
him out here is a photo of him and Roger
Federer also we do have another one also
of him and Roger Federer and here is a
goofy one of him when he was a bit
younger also we have a photo of him
teaching his children how to play chess
and this is one where he teaches his
daughter and this is the one where his
son is making the moves so there some
photos for us to enjoy now let's see the
game he's playing against a person named
Igor Oskar from Moldova now as we don't
know who this person is that is the
reason the hoodie guys there again and
the reason why I'm wearing a hoodie for
those of you who are maybe new to this
channel so let's see the game
Igor Rossi opens with III it's a opening
that you will very rarely see it's
called the van crew is opening after
Dutch Dutch master Martin van truest who
who won the Dutch championship a long
long time ago with this move like it I
mean you will very rarely see this but
I've actually seen it in a tournament I
played this year were a colleague of
mine from my home town defeated well he
didn't defeat him he outplayed
completely aphelion master with III but
then he was the game afterwards but ok
Lubitsch counters with d5 we have d4 and
now II 6 I will have Knight to f3 Knight
to f6 transposing into the Col system h3
and brush-up to d6 now I will not tell
you the rating of the players but it is
something you will have to guess for
ourselves so feel free to comment to add
your maybe suggestions in the comments
how how high rated do you think these
players are and we have Knight to c3
Knight to c3 by white it's always better
to proceed for example c4 immediately
and only after this pawn is pushed then
play Knight to c3 you don't want to
block your pawn with the night
so Knights the c6 and we have a tree now
it's a move that can be useful it's not
really something you want to play maybe
simply continue developing with Bishop
to d3 but all right
Bishop to d7 Bishop to D - we have
castles and knights to b5 now going for
that Bishop on d6 which seems like a
reasonable idea Bishop to e7 loob she
doesn't want to give up his Bishop air
so he retreats with the bishop and now
Knight the e5 Knight captures the
detectors on e5 and now Knight to e8
Knight the e4 or might be an interesting
idea but Luke which seems to follow
follow the famous eventual principle
that the hardest move is with the knight
back but I mean if if the night is
finally 4 then it's always better to go
forwards and backwards maybe go
immediately for this Bishop and the
private white of his bishop pair but ok
knife to e8 preparing f6 to break break
white center and here mr. Eagle Roger
please f4 f4 is a blunder but here we
seem to have a case of double blindness
as Luigi follows up with his plan of
pushing f6 whereas here is a nice moment
for you to kind of pause the video and
find that the move that actually could
have been played which wins a piece for
black so it's not it's not that
difficult but it's Bishop to h4 would
check now it doesn't matter if you block
this with the g3 black will simply
capture and at one point you will have
to play King to e2 then the bishop will
no longer be defending the knight on b5
and then Bishop captures on b5 will
simply win a piece but ok it was a 10
minute game 10 minutes each zero seconds
increments so you know tactics will be
missed which is to be expected I mean
even Samuel Shanklin and misses some
tactics we have f6 and Bishop to c3 we
have a a six-night goes to D for F
captures on e5 f captures on e5 and now
better up to g5
going after the debt III pawn queen to
e2 why the defense this and now Bishop
to h6 I was I was actually very
impressed by this Bishop to h6 move I
wish makes room for the Queen to come to
g5 you might immediately get the urge of
going Bishop to h4 but after Bishop - 4
check yes you do force the King
the one you've the problem of castling
and then immediately you maybe want to
write it down with rook to f2 seems very
aggressive and very powerful but
actually after Queen to g4 like it
doesn't really have anything here and
you have to be very careful for example
now if you proceed c5 and Knight moves
Knight f3 and now what what this rook
really doesn't have anywhere to go
the bishop is attacked twice and have to
remove the bishop Queen g3 will win the
rook now you have to give up the
exchange either you'll capture the
bishop or denied and then white is
simply up the exchange so Bishop h6 a
nice quiet move we have queenside castle
and bush or Queen to g5 now going after
d3 pawn we have Knight to f3 as you
can't defend both months the e3 pawn is
attacked and also d5 pawn so why decided
to protect d5 for Knight to f3 and now
comes Queen captures so grabbing upon
Queen captures Bishop captures with
check King b1 and now you [ __ ] is up a
pawn we have c5 Bishop to d2 offering a
trader bishops Bishop captures rook
captures and here you definitely want to
continue with a move like b5 but we seem
to have a case of another case of double
blindness Luke which proceeds here with
c4 c4 doesn't work in this particular
situation and you know I'm pretty sure
maybe you want to pause the video see
why it doesn't work is because the
bishop on d7 is undefended so here a
wife could actually capture this but
your captures and a if you capture
didn't ro capture some d7 so black would
actually give up his extra pawn if if
white proceeded as he should have
but after C for white decided to go for
a different plan rook to d4 now we have
night to c7 where Bishop to c4 is still
an idea but white continues with his
plan he's not interested in winning upon
rock to h4 with ideas of Knight to g5
followed by Knight captures or ro
captures on h7
we have b5 further expanding on the
Queen side and now Knight to g5
going after the h7 point which is a bit
weird plan
Luigi simply plays h6 and he kills the
knight back so as you can see whites
white previous 5 moves were rook coming
to d4 then rook coming to h4 Knight
coming to g5 knife coming back to f3 so
all of these moves were basically
stopped by this one h6 move so it's not
not a plan you wanna really commit to as
you know if if white just thought about
what he was doing he would see that h6
prevents everything but okay
a5 further expanding on the Queen side
and now we have Knights to d4 and night
to d4 seems like a powerful square for
the knight yes the knight does occupy
central square but where's the night
gonna go be v c6 the bishop bishop on d7
you might think that it's not very
active but it's actually controlling all
of the squares that this knife can go to
and later he it can easily be activated
we have Bishop to eight to g6 so okay we
have B for a capture some before a
capture some before and g4 g4 is is an
interesting move that prepares g5 of
course white wants to break open here
all the files on the King side play rope
do you want maybe but here also I was
very impressed by this move Liberty she
plays the strongest move recommended by
the engine he plays rook to f4 and now
white is no longer able to push g5 as
the rock on h4 is undefended also the
knight on d4 is under attack and after
the knight moves then the rook is coming
to e4 to attack d5 pawn so here Knight
to e2 was played you could try and move
like c3 but c3 then you open up this
diagonal then Bishop to v8 is coming and
this would be very uncomfortable for
white for example if you play something
like let's say Bishop to e2 you have to
play something then Bishop to g6 check
King moves and rook to a1 will pick up
the h1 rook so I have to rope to f4 we
have Knight to e2
rook to e4 attacking the knight and now
rook to h2 the preparing to defend the
night and maybe go to go to f2 and place
the rook and g2 at the worship and you
Rock captures only five there was really
no way of defending this pawn Knight the
c1 and the now night Stewie one painting
that night and see one Bishop to e2 and
here it's a very interesting position
black is completely winning here and
there are there are a couple of
interesting ways you can win this game
in the game luigi's played b3 which is
which is also winning but there is
another interesting way of winning it
Lubitsch went for for the win and the
queenside but there is I mean there is
another win on the Queen side which is C
3 C 3 wins immediately because now this
C pawn is guarding the D 2 square and
there is no defense against rook
captures on c1 even if you capture here
for example pawn captures pawn captures
there's really no way of stopping this
the knight can't move the knight is
pinned and there is no defense of rook
captures here now whatever you play rook
F 2 then rook captures on c1 is coming
team captures and rook to a 1 this will
be checkmate but instead of b3 s or
instead of c3 luigi she played b3 and
again there's really no no stopping this
his opponent in this position played
rock g2 and here is a nice position for
you to solve it's actually checkmate in
two so free to pause the video and find
the checkmate so as usual I will give it
a couple of seconds for you to the side
for those of you who found it
congratulations you are an excellent
checkmater in - and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show now as you
can see before c3 was played so d2 was
covered now b3 was played so a2 is
covered so in this instance rook to a-1
check the King has no moves king - a one
has the capture and now rook captures
nikon c1 and this is again checkmate
because the pawn is covering the a2
square so yeah that's the game even you
[ __ ] vs. evil ruler of moldova also
the hoody guy here I do hope you enjoyed
it and yeah
you [ __ ] promise that the next time
he will play chess against Roger Federer
that he will record that game and
we will also be able to enjoy that game
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank you for
sending me this game and yeah as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with another
another series thank you all